i will now show you my preferred way of
finding an inverse of a three by three
matrix and i actually think it's a lot
more fun and you're less likely to make
careless mistakes but if i remember
correctly from algebra two they didn't
teach they didn't teach it this way in
algebra two and that's why i taught the
other way initially but let's go through
this and in a future video i will teach
you why it works because that's always
important but in linear algebra this is
one of the few subjects where i think
it's very important to learn how to do
the operations first and then later
we'll learn the why because the how is
very mechanical and it really just
involves some basic arithmetic for the
most part
but the the y is
tends to be quite deep so i'll leave
that to uh later videos and you can
often think about the depth of things
when you know when you have confidence
that you at least understand the hows so
anyway let's go back to our original
matrix
and what was that original matrix that i
did in the last video it was
one
zero one
1 1 1. and we wanted to find the inverse
of this matrix
so this is what what we're going to do
is called gauss jordan elimination
to find the inverse of the matrix and
the way you do it and it might seem a
little bit like magic it might seem a
little bit like voodoo but i think if
what you'll see in future videos it
makes a lot of sense what we do is we
augment this matrix and what does
augment mean it means you just add
something to it so i draw a dividing
line some people don't
so if i put a dividing line here
and what i put on the other divide on
the other side of the dividing line
i put the identity matrix of the same
size so this is 3 by 3 so i put a three
by three identity matrix so that's one
zero
zero one
zero zero one
all right so what are we going to do
what i'm going to do is perform a series
of elementary row operations and i'm
about to tell you what are valid
elementary row operations on this matrix
but whatever i do to any of these rows
here i have to do the corresponding rows
here and my goal is essentially to
perform a bunch of operations on the
left hand side and of course the same
operations will be applied to the right
hand side so that i eventually end up
with the identity matrix on the left
hand side and then when i have the
identity matrix on the left-hand side
what i have left on the right-hand side
will be the inverse of this original
matrix and when you put this in and when
you this becomes an identity matrix
that's actually called reduced row
echelon form and i'll talk more a lot
about that there's a lot of a lot of
names and labels and linear algebra but
they're really you know just fairly
simple concepts but anyway let's get
started and this should um become a
little clearer at least the the process
will become clear maybe not why it works
so first of all i said i'm going to
perform a bunch of operations here what
are legitimate operations they're called
elementary row operations so there's a
couple of things i can do
i can replace any row with that row
multiplied by some number so i could do
that i can swap
any two rows
and of course if i swap say the first
row the second row i'd have to do it
here as well
and i can add or subtract one row from
another row so when i do that so for
example i could take this row and
replace it with this row added to this
row and you'll see what i mean in a
second and you know if you combine it
you could you could say well i'm going
to multiply this row times negative 1
and add it to this row and replace this
row with that
so if if you if you start to feel like
this is something like what you learned
when you learn system of equations or
solving systems of linear equations
that's no coincidence because
matrices are actually a very good way to
represent it and i will show you that
soon
but anyway let's do some elementary row
operations to get this left hand side
into reduced row echelon form which is
really just a fancy way of saying let's
turn it into the identity matrix
so let's see what we want to do we want
to have ones all across here we want
these to be zero so let's see how we can
do this efficiently
so let me draw the matrix again
so let's
let's uh let's let's get a i want to get
a 0 here
right that would be convenient so i'm
going to keep the top two rows the same
1 0 1
i have my dividing line
1 0 0. i didn't do anything there i'm
not doing anything to the second row
zero two
one
zero two one
zero
one zero
and what i'm going to do i'm going to
replace this row and just you know my
motivation my goal is to get a zero here
so i'm a little bit closer to you know
having a uh the identity matrix here
so how do i get a zero here well what i
could do is i can subtract i can replace
this row
with
this row minus this row so i can replace
the third row with the third row minus
the first row so what's the third row
minus the first row
one minus one is
zero
one minus zero
is one
one minus one is zero
well i did it on the left hand side so i
have to do it on the right hand side i
have to replace this with this minus
this so zero minus one is
minus one zero minus zero is zero
and one minus zero is one
fair enough
now what can i do
well this
this this row right here this third row
it has zero one zero it looks a lot like
what i want for my second row in the
identity matrix so why don't i just swap
these two rows why don't i just swap the
first and second rows so let's do that
i'm going to swap the first and second
rows so the first row stays the same one
zero one
and then on the other side it stays the
same as well
and i am swapping the first sorry the
second and third rows so now my second
row is now zero one zero and i have to
swap it on the right hand side so it's
minus 1 0 1 right i'm just
i'm just swapping these two
so then my third row now becomes what
the second row was here 0 2 1
and
0 1 0.
fair enough
now what do i want to do well it would
be nice if i had a 0 right here that
would get me that much closer to the
identity matrix so how could i put it
get a 0 here well what if i subtracted
2 times row 2 from row 1 right because
then this would be 1 times 2 is 2 and if
i subtracted if i if i subtracted that
from this i would get a 0 here so let's
do that
so the first row
the first row has has been very lucky it
hasn't had to do anything it's just
sitting there
one zero one
one zero
zero
and the second row is not changing for
now minus one zero one
now what did i say i was going to do
i'm going to subtract two times row two
from row three
so
this is zero minus two times zero is
zero
two minus two times one
well that's zero
one minus two times zero
is one
minus 2 times negative 1
is so 0 let's remember 0
minus 2 times negative 1 so that's 0
minus negative 2 so that's positive two
one minus two times zero
well that's just still one
zero
minus two times one so that's minus two
right have i done that right i just want
to make sure 0 minus
2 times
right 2 times -1 is minus 2 and i'm
subtracting it so it's plus
okay so i'm close this almost looks like
the identity matrix or reduced row
echelon form except for this one right
here so i'm finally going to have to
touch
the top row
and what what can i do
well how about i replace the top row
with the top row minus the bottom row
right because if i subtract this from
that this will get a zero there so let's
do that so i'm replacing the top row
with the top row minus the third row
so one minus zero is one
zero minus zero
is zero
one minus one is
zero that was our whole goal
and then one minus two
is negative one
zero
minus one is negative one
minus negative 2 well that's positive 2
and then the other rows stay the same
right
0 1 0
minus 1
0 1
and then
0 0 1
1 negative 2.
and there you have it we have performed
a series of operations on the left hand
side and we performed the same
operations on the right hand side
this became the identity matrix
or reduced row echelon form and we did
this using gauss-jordan elimination
and what is this
well this is the inverse of this
original matrix
this times this will equal the identity
matrix so this if this is a inverse i'm
sorry if this is a
then this is a inverse
and that's all you have to do and as you
can see this took me half the amount of
time it required a lot less hairy
mathematics than when i did it using you
know the add joint and the cofactors and
the determinant
and if you think about it i'll give you
a little hint of why this worked
every one of these operations i did on
this on the left hand side
every one of those operations you could
kind of view them as multiplying
you know to get from here to here i
multiplied you can kind of say that
there's a matrix that if i multiplied by
that matrix it would have performed this
operation and then i would have had to
multiply by another matrix top to do
this operation so essentially what we
did is we multiplied by a series of
matrices to get here
and when if you multiplied all of those
what we call elimination matrices
together you essentially multiply this
times the inverse so what am i saying so
if we have a
if to go from
to go from
here to here we have to multiply a times
the elimination matrix
and this might be completely confusing
for you so ignore it if it is but it
might be insightful so we you know they
called we eliminated what did we
eliminate in this we eliminated three
one we multiplied by the elimination
matrix 3 1 to get here
right and then we to go from here to
here we multiplied by some matrix and
i'll tell you more i'll show you how we
can construct these elimination matrixes
we multiply by elimination matrix well
actually we we had a row swap here
um i don't know what you want to call
that we could call that you know
the swap matrix
i don't know we swapped two for three
row two for three
and then here we had eliminate we
multiplied by elimination matrix what
did we do this was we eliminated this so
this was row three column two three two
and then finally to get here we had to
multiply by elimination matrix we have
to eliminate this right here so we
eliminated
row one column three so elimination with
row one comma three and i want you to
know right now that it's not important
what these matrices are i'll show you
how we can construct these matrices but
i just want you to have kind of a leap
of faith that each of these operations
could have been done by multiplying by
some matrix matrix right but we do know
is by multiplying by all of these
matrices we essentially got the identity
matrix
back here
so
the combination of all of these matrices
when you multiply by the each other this
must be the inverse matrix
if i were to multiply each of these
elimination and swap row swap matrices
this must be the inverse matrix of a
right because when you multiply all of
them times a you get the inverse
well well what happened if if these
matrices are collectively the inverse
matrix if i do them if i multiply the
identity matrix times them you know the
elimination matrix you know this one
times that equals that this one times
that equals that this one times that
equals that and so forth i'm essentially
multiplying when you combine all of
these a inverse times the identity
matrix right so if you think about it
just very big picture and i don't want
to confuse you it's good enough at this
point if you just understood what i did
but what i'm doing from all of these
steps i'm essentially multiplying both
sides of this
augmented matrix you could call it by
a inverse so i multiplied this by a
inverse to get to the identity matrix
but then of course if i multiply the
inverse matrix times the identity matrix
i'll get the inverse matrix but anyway i
don't want to confuse you hopefully that
gave you a little intuition i'll do this
later with some more concrete examples
but but hopefully you see that this is a
lot less hairy than the way we did it
with the adjoint and the cofactors and
the minor matrices and the determinants
etcetera anyway i'll see you in the next
video